you can't tell by watching tony on the
trampoline but the impact of his parents
assault on him reads as a long list
every limb was broken in his body in
several places his big toes were
dislocated his ankle was dislocated
you know these were horrific injuries
blunt trauma to his face he's definitely
his right ear
he has deformed ribs
he's missing his left hip so he will
need
hip replacements throughout his life it
can't be reconstructed you know the list
is endless
it's why his new family have campaigned
to see child abusers jailed for longer
they still pose a huge risk to society
especially children
you know i wouldn't like them near any
children that i know or and they could
be
anywhere
anthony smith and jody simpson were both
due to be released this year after being
jailed in 2018 for their assault on tony
but under the new law the justice
secretary can refer individuals set for
release to the parole board which then
gets to decide if it's safe to the
public for them to be freed
what should happen to those people who
are in jail
um they should be
a sentence of their life one
and make
them stay in prison for
for more days
so they don't harm other children or
or do anything bad like they used to do
under the police crime sentencing and
courts act referred to as tony's law
child abusers will see tougher sentences
up to life in prison increased from the
previous 14-year maximum
i doubt that it will have a deterrent
effect
i i really do
um because people who commit these sorts
of offences are hardly thinking i'll do
this because i'll only get 10 years i
won't do it if i think i'm going to get
12 years
the government says the sentencing
changes are to protect the most
vulnerable the hajjal family say it
doesn't go far enough in punishing the
pair who left their child with such
life-changing injuries
sadia chowdhury sky news